ich mag dort als nix da ist auch meine
am schiffen gespielt
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem survival games sechs einzelrunden
event organisiert von der person die
rechts neben mir steht nämlich war wie
letztes mal auch aber diesmal ist wieder
halt diese einzelrunde wo jeder alleine
drauf los kämpft allerdings ist es
erlaubt mit anderen leuten währenddessen
zu skypen und auszutauschen
wir dürfen kein team machen um meine
pace kindes auf im moment wieder am
start und mit mir hier dabei ist sind
mail
hallo minecraft freunde halo reach
freude
wir sind aber auch noch plätze frei das
hat viele leute aber es sollten
eigentlich noch kommen und sonic und so
kommen kamen sie aber nicht
überlingens fitnessstudio und kommet
rollt und rollt alle und kommt einfach
nicht so da oben die map ist relativ
klein oder da oben ist schon glas
begrenzung oder dass der spot vermissen
auch kein planet der ist sie ist dies
mega groß ist megagroß sie kommt auch
gar nicht klar ist wirkte stunde dauern
bis wir irgendwann finden
nein ich bin nicht gesprintet am anfang
ja man ich hab gar nichts weiß haben
erfahrungs fläschchen wenn ich habe gar
nichts neues in der rattles nach haben
jetzt wieder dieses das war eine junge
und schreit ich weiß nicht keine ahnung
wann ich hab echt kein plan
ich habe auch kein plan vor allem in den
städten auch auf online das heißt es ist
ein scheiß problem also wenn ich jetzt
eine an schreibt dann bin ich hier ich
muss nur wenige kiste suche mich kurz
versteckt und dann mache ich mich in
skyrim aufgeschreckt
ich mach das jetzt eben so sagt man
sieht man welche leute schon die map
gezockt haben wir ja die leute direkt
irgendwohin laufen weil ich habe die
noch kein einziges mal nicht schon tot
fick deine mutter look place als ob ya
ha wo warst du denn so macht das
irgendwo einem schiff gemacht ohne
respekt gar keinen sinn
ja ich bin gerade auch irgendwie nur am
laufen und muss etliche kisten und man
nicht doch das sehen alter ja genau geht
direkt auf mich drauf penner lasst mich
doch ja so macht das spaß prime games
hey wenn man direkt auf einen drauf geht
das natürlich cool also wir sind alle
schon so da denke ich werde die die team
runde dann einfach direkt hinter allen
so und da sind wir in der team- runde es
gab zwar vorhin schon eine team runde
allerdings wurde ich davon simon nach 20
sekunden getötet weil er das nicht
mitbekommen hat dass wir eine grace
periode von einer minute haben oder sie
man einfach nicht in lesen kann kein
plan wieder mit am start in lippe wir
haben uns gedacht dass wir jetzt einfach
mal kicken aber übel werden jetzt
richtig verwerten
ohne scheiß ich denke mal los jetzt
überall rein egal ob sie müll hexel also
den mund von jemandem wo bist du
eigentlich ich hab keine ahnung wo bist
du denn ich sehe hier
daraus konkret aus weiter weiter weiter
räder kommt noch ein bisschen hin wo wir
hin mit dem investor und ja bitte
ich hoffe ich werde nicht wieder direkte
schreiben nicht geschlagen werde an der
kasse aus ich habe mir nicht ich habe
fisch und pilz wo bist du
wo bist du okay laufen laut comcom mit
komik offen wohin
okay ich habe schon eine idee ich hab
schon eine idee voraus nämlich eine
kiste gleich in der kiste ja schon
diamant und so was drinnen und dafür
natürlich genommen ok soll man in dieses
gebäude hier rein laufen ich weiß nicht
etwa die gebäude ab und ich guck mal
hier draußen sind irgendwo kisten diese
kissen ja lassen sondern nur diese
kisten die aussehen wie pisten
ich habe stein schwert ich hab dich eine
steinachs wo bist du in diesem haus da
wohl gemeinte techno house plan
ich bin neben einem haus in der schmiede
in so ein parcours hoch geübt oder gar
zum paloma ich mal wieder
ich sehe dich aber nur welche sachen
redet und ohne witz man befasst was
bringt zum handy
ich habe für dich ein 1 1 dingens eine
steinachs haben den erst mal ins gesicht
klar du kannst mir da noch hin
ich weiß nicht ob ich sagen wir gehen
sehr defensiv okay ich bin voll gewöhnen
die anderen ist noch ein zu gucken
direkt hinter den rücken frei ja ich
weiss ich nicht ich weiß nicht so
einfach die stadt durch noten weil macht
es glaube ich keinen sinn wenn wir
rausgehen oder ja das einfach hier
bleiben ich hoffe ich jetzt keinen namen
doch da unten nach oben sieht alles noch
so ist das
ich sehe da unten ein name ich sehe ganz
kunden sind kali bohren wolf 58 ist
scheiße
die können nichts nenne ich bin hier
oben auf dem baum
ich bin es genau über die in dem haus
über die auf dem haus drauf und die
kiste drin war passte schuhe und
überschuhe ja habe ich jetzt keinen sinn
ich gucke jetzt einfach in alle kisten
regal jeder wenig sonne david am
liebsten sein sind welche daten
ungespielt alter da hinten gespielt wo
komme aus dem haus raus hilfe groß raus
simon simon fakt die [ __ ] [ __ ] sich
die welken laub lukrativer kommt die
hoch- oder romano diese blöden lässig
getötet hat war war sie mal wieder in
einem team mit links mit modernster kenn
ich ja ich bin halt einfach total schals
an diesen ganzen sachen es halt so
erwarte ich meine zuschauer ihr könnt
jetzt noch sehen was ich mache ich
verstecke ich habe angst vor den beiden
wichtigen penner alter wie schnecken
ich sag dir wo die sind wie horst rettig
ist sie gar nichts mehr
aber egal spielte trotzdem ein bisschen
rum damit ihr ein bisschen was zu gucken
hat ein paar impressionen von der mittel
eingenommen
wo bist du weil da sind kommen tronic wo
bist du denn hin gelaufen so eine
schnecke da sind die gerade ich bin ganz
unten beide tief für mich gehen zu den
schiffen hin ich war hungrig zu essen
habe deshalb ist es auch vorab gefragt
das ganze komplett klicken hier mit mir
das kannst du es vergessen aber warte
mal da oben ist der fall er hat sehr
viel spaß gemacht mein fazit war das war
auf jeden fall dahin ist mein mich
wirklich töten
der bessere sachen etwas hat meine
sachen das thema soll die neue weg vor
mir du penner du musst mir folgen
die kamera von sky ein bisschen zu
langsam den kopf voll komisch
doch jetzt gehen der ist immer komisch
komisch komisch ja ich kann nicht
sprechen es sich aber friedlich ich kann
nicht mehr sprinten das ganze auch
knicken ich jetzt nichts was er gar
nicht hoch lesen alle lehrer ich mach
doch da ist nix da ist auch meine am
schiff alles eingespielt nur vor dem
welcher weg gelaufen und simon
die mitte stellen
ich hasse dies ohne die bayern ist davon
machen
er sieht sie nicht
etwas machen die trading egal in der
runde
was sollen wir kommen unseren kreis
kleve wenn wir mit simon und neuruppin
machen dann sterben wenn ich ihr könnt
ihn zum ritter ist so lasst uns mal
gleich klären
wir klären wo wir klären und die betten
uns war richtig und ich würde das sofort
in der junior oder wieder am montag
wünsche euch und da sind wir auch schon
in der euroleague 64 mit msi eco gut
dach und dna und um gespielt und jetzt
geht's los
okay dann sag ich erst in der mitte zwei
mal haben wir wieder bis er sagt dass
dann losgeht
ich habe ich bin hinter simon
wo seid ihr denn da wo du bist und ich
bin rausgelaufen kommt doch anders da
glaube ich dachte ihr laufen diesem weg
hätten schiffe da wir treffen uns meinen
schiffen kommt allemal
wir laufen rund anspruch nehmen
das wasser rein springen das ein meter
tiefe kannst du wenn du das was er
trifft nicht so wie das thema kirche
gebrochen
dort habe ich habe ich hab mir ich hab
mir gut sagt man heute ja meist auf dem
boden kein ding jetzt richtig genutzt so
hart trifft er wissen ob wir sind zu
dritt in moskau nicht gibt auch okay und
die kisten
ich habe irgendwie zwischen ex also
keine ahnung wenn ich jetzt aber luca
luka scham holstein schwer für dich du
bist du da hinter luca hinter dir
luca nicht optimal daten schwer für mich
leute leute müssen verteidigen
da habt ihr leut ich wenn mir da ja drei
a- team
zufälligerweise simon ich bin hier am
strand konzentrieren madrid plant
veröffentlichen
dann wird es mit dem kot gar nichts mehr
conny der kamera oder antike gar nicht
ausführen helfen wusste
naja wenn die tat umsetzen was mir auch
geschickt habt luca dahlhoff dass ich
hab das dena geschickt habt nein ich hab
dir dass du dich hab ich nur
hingeschickt von rosen bekommen was und
hat in der konfi so drin als wir geredet
haben ja zufälligerweise hinein drinnen
redet doch ich bin der konflikt wird
darüber geredet dass ihr das mit dem
supercup mich zu töten wollte so stammen
die vier kalou comeback ich wollte nicht
dass er herkommt dann wollte so richtig
runter springen wie ein stein schwerte
haben simon beckett kommt von hinten
nicht raus
ok mal kurz an die zuschauer werden so
planen dass wir waren zu sechst team und
ich wollte dann kurz sagen und dann
gehen alle auf nur noch drauf und dann
sagt keiner was dann noch übrig sie dann
voll auf und wir halt alle dann ganz
lang machen nächste mal wieder vergessen
machen
das gebäude immer mehr der winter kommt
immer näher
simon sprankel oder so was ich kann halt
nicht so gut aufholen das ist echt
schwer treffen am strand die welt auch
weiter schnell andere sachen als wolf
und karl niveau zusammen bis hin zu
zweit
jetzt springt er ist am strand oder
musste mein team ist auch weg ich bin
hinter euch her gesprungen die ganze
zeit
ok dann gehe ich noch mal im kreis
treffen
das wasser suchte patchwork jetzt von
kunststoffen muss nicht gleich am strand
tot
und jetzt sagen wir alle angehen auf den
code und bekommt trotzdem keine chance
egal
unser plan ist gut ich würde einfach
sagen